what I'm really concerned about is the
fact that within universities a very
liberal ethos has become
institutionalized where for the first
time a growing number of young people
actually think that freedom is not a big
deal hi I'm Nicholas B with reason TV
today we are talking with Frank Ferretti
he's an emeritus professor at the
university of kansas sociologist and the
author of most recently what happened to
the university a sociological
exploration of its infantilization Frank
thanks for talking to us pleasure okay
so what is so bad about the university
right now what did what's the thesis of
the book I think what the book suggests
is that there was a time when
universities were a place where you
could spontaneously interact where free
speech academic freedom were really
valued as a place of experimentation and
risk-taking where you could really go to
the edge of the world look over the
cliff and and just basically make things
happen
West today what has happened is that in
many respects the university has become
far more as sort of conservative far
more restrictive far more inward looking
and very very liberal so in many
respects easier to speak about
controversial subjects outside of the
university than inside the universe it's
a historic role reversal where the
university has become far more
censorious than the rest of society and
that's when they got my very troubling
is the entire university being
infantilized as its students and what
are the causes of that well what I mean
by infantile ization is a situation
where the line that used to exist
between high school and university has
become eroded where young men and young
women coming to university regard
themselves and are treated as if they
were biologically mature children where
is a powerful impulse towards
paternalism where you look after 18 19
21 year-olds instead of allowing them to
make their way in the world and the
whole the basically the whole of the
teaching profession has almost
reorganized its pedagogy or around the
assumption
but essentially you're dealing with
clever children rather than with
independently minded young men and
you're luminous and that's what I mean
by centralized is what are the causes
driving that because it so
eighteen-year-olds when they show up or
17 18 19 year olds they're no longer
treated as adults they're still treated
as children why is that well what I
argue is that in many respects where the
problem really lies in the failure of
adult society to socialize young people
to educate them for freedom and
independence where historically in
America in England
young people were socialized into values
but what is right and what is wrong the
importance of freedom of self-reliance
and responsibility a whole set of values
and even if the kids didn't really live
up to they knew that these were
aspirationally quite important and as a
result of that you know when you're a 14
or 15 or 16 you were dying to become a
grown-up you kind of pretended to be a
young man or a young women I was today I
think what we've done is instead of
socializing people into values we rely
on psychological techniques as a
substitute so what does that mean yeah
that means for example that parent soft
or told not to criticize their children
but instead to smile at them so when
kids do something wrong you don't say
you've been a bad person but you know
this is a bad you know sort of act that
that that was scared us you kind of turn
into your psychologist as a mother or a
father and your ago you Charles the
patient because the the connection is
that children are so powerless and
fragile that unless you emotionally
support and raise their self-esteem
they're going to have long-term damage
to their self-esteem and Terasaki and
what's even worse the schools carry on
doing that and if you look at the system
of education that has evolved it's got a
pedagogy that's really about you know
sort of validating them making them feel
good about themselves
very rarely criticizing them minimizing
the pressure that they're under making
sure they're not too competitive against
each other and there is also that what
happens is that they the kids are
quarantined from the pressures of
everyday life is that true at all levels
of class or are we talking you know
first of
universities I mean about 2/3 or a
little bit more than 2/3 of high school
students in America go on to some form
of college immediately
I suspect it's about the same or maybe a
little bit lower in England but is this
in all classes or is this really are we
talking about rich people who are afraid
that their kids can't make you know
can't make the grade so they want they
want to get rid of those kinds of
judgments well as you're suggesting a
lot of these customs begin in the more
sort of wealthy affluent areas of
society they're the ones that innovated
the ideas of new forms of sensitivity
training of bringing in emotional
literacy so truly a set of practices
that begins amongst a small section of
society but it were 25 30 years it got
gradually filters done so that in more
recent decades particularly since the
turn of the 20th 21st century even
people coming from less wealthy
backgrounds become influenced by this
and parents come from working-class
backgrounds begin to internalize or
under pressure to internalize these
forms of behavior if you look at a
typical parenting class that there's
given to working-class of very poor
people the the workshops for parents are
all about making them into amateur
therapists who are going to them you
know sort of make sure that they will so
are you you're calling for parents to
hit their children that's what I'm
hearing well I know be harsh on them no
I
what I'm arguing for is that being in
kids of the relationship it's its
relations between a mother and a father
and a child you got to make a lot of
mistakes and the course of bringing your
kids up and you're going to learn from
those mistakes and the child will also
learn that the mums and dads do things
that are real unexpected or wrong but in
the course of doing that the child
becomes stronger and I think your job as
a parent is to encourage your
independence to provide them with the
support they need to stand on their two
feet to make the judgment calls where
occasionally you allow them to take
risks even though you know that it's
possible that they may graze their knees
and they might get into trouble but
instead of immunizing them from the
pressures of everyday life you
your job is to actually make sure that
they becomes strongest as soon as
possible so it you know in a kind of
contemporary American debate a lot of
the times college is treated as that's a
stage that people come to and whatever
is happening there is because of what's
happening on the campus you're
essentially arguing that if you're
focusing on college you're missing where
all of this stuff is actually coming
from so you you could be treating the
symptom but not to cause that's right I
said at the same time although as I
argue almost all the developments do
with the people's sort of physical and
moral behavior occurs a long time before
category university nevertheless the
universities are really important
indirectly because you have to remember
that university is not a massive
institution for example at the
university's influence the values of the
teaching profession so all the schools
are inhabited by people who gone to
university themselves who internalized
the kind of values and practices that
are popular universities they also
influenced a very large section of
society or pet the parents because most
a lot of parents the growing number of
parents have gone to college themselves
so indirectly the values that are
created and constructed within the
university environment or I would argue
the most powerful drivers of
socialization are they is there an
ideological basis in that or is this
kind of a blind procession of well
people the people at university are in
education schools or in psychology they
just think they're doing things right or
is it that they have a particular
ideology that they're trying to impart
well I suppose you could say there's an
ideological element as long as you see
ideology with a small I in other it's
not a political ideology that's being
promoted but for example a lot of the
teaching profession or the people
getting involved with social work
learned very very fast that that job is
really to save children from their
parents their job is to make sure that
these fairly sick stupid parents who are
completely insensitive to the needs of
their child
somehow get some skills from them that
necessary to bring those kinds of kids
up so there's a kind of mission there
that's promoted to the location of
teaching and social work and other
helping professions do have an
ideological underpinning but it's not a
left thing or a right wing or a liberal
ideology it could simply have a
particular orientation towards the human
self where do we see the negative
effects I mean you say okay but you know
let's let's grant that children and
young adults or society is becoming more
infantilized actual adults even twenty
people in their 20s are being treated
like children what's the harm in that
in the sense of you know crime in most
places is down you know people live
longer they you know they you know they
seem to be about as happy if they've
ever been if there's something wrong
with that well not necessarily because I
know in my case myself and all my
friends did everything possible to delay
growing up and and having fun and nobody
wanted to turn into a gray suited you
know office worker at the age of 21 you
wanted to explore the world and wanted
to make things happen so all those
aspirations are entirely positive I'm
not really against that but what I'm
talking about something a little bit
different it's not about an aspiration
to experiment to take risk and to avoid
responsibility in order to do something
transformative or or or interesting it's
basically it's an avoidance of growing
up in order to stay still and to avoid
the pressures that come with becoming an
older person and I think that the way
you can see the downside of this are
developments like the fact that in the
Western world people living at home or
the fastest-growing demographic group
you have situations in Japan where you
know leaving home is seen as almost an
impossible ask for many many young
people as I've done interviews with
young men and young women in line in
England who are late twenties early
thirties come from very relatively
affluent backgrounds and when I stand
why are you living in mom and dad they
say well you know it's very comfortable
you know
did she cook stuff for me and when I
asked them well what do you do with your
girlfriend's your boyfriend's it's not
no problem I can bring them home and I
said well you know is that the high
point of your ambition that you go spend
and you're upstairs in a bedroom a
moment that are watching television you
know sort of I think the bizarre
development well okay but let me ask you
in the book you talk about coming-of-age
in the Universities and the 60s and the
70s and you talk about the activism then
but are you just trying to replicate
your experience as a child and you know
you're now at an age where you know are
you just nostalgic for your past and you
want you want the world to be the way it
was when you were growing up well of the
danger that we've become caricatures
ourselves and merely yes sort of want to
rediscover the past in the future and I
really hope that's not what I'm doing
because as a sociologist I know that
history never repeats itself and
experiences and cultural norms always
mutate and change it's impossible to
imagine that the 1960s are going to come
back you know 10 or 20 years down the
road but what I'm really concerned about
is it's not to rediscover my generation
what I'm really concerned about is the
fact that within universities a very
illiberal ethos has become
institutionalized where for the first
time you know since modern the modern
era a growing number of young people
actually think that freedom is not a big
deal and they're quite you know sort of
upfront about it they are in your face
when they say well what's what's the big
deal about freedom or free speech what
are you going about academic freedom so
what so so what if we censor somebody
from saying something that's offensive
so what if a certain academic is forced
to watch their word that's a small price
to pay for us being comfortable and when
you have that kind of acceptance of of
this kind of semi totalitarian impulse
towards closing discussion down that is
really worrying I mean particularly at
the universities you were saying because
that's the one place you could say you
could see that in a workplace maybe but
the whole idea of the university is that
that's where that happens that's right
and it's interesting how how powerful it
is a
the man who's Hungarian was invited to
go to Florida to give lectures on the
Hungarian Holocaust and he's totally
unaware what goes on in universities and
he's showing a picture of Auschwitz and
and basically the picture shows a woman
before she got to Austria it's a
beautiful Jewish woman in 1939 and that
shows the picture of the same woman you
know sort of skin and bones you know
after all shoe it looking like almost
like a corpse and this woman in the in
the auditorium cries dad stop it stop it
I came to hear a lecture on the
Holocaust and and you know I'm offended
everything up so my friend just looks at
me and says well actually this is
electron Holocaust and you know what did
you expect you know so a Disney
representation of a fairy tale and he
said that was the end of the matter
yeah you know I day literally gets
called him by the Dean and said this is
not how we do things in our university I
guess basically recommended for
discussing a disturbing theme and if we
come to that point where you can't even
discuss the Holocaust as a Holocaust but
you got to have a business side version
of it then we are in big trouble
you've identified the problem you've
discussed some of the root causes and
the development over time and the
effects of it what what is what are the
means of redress what can we do to you
know kind of make force the universities
and society they've become more mature
well I think that's a really big problem
because there's a simple answer for that
I think universities need to take ideas
a little bit more seriously because if
you take ideas seriously for example if
you think that freedom is actually a big
deal then you're far less likely to
accommodate to censorious trends you're
going to stand up and be counted you
have to really go to our way to
popularize the importance of many of the
elementary liberal north tolerance and
freedom democracy which have become
emptied of meaning at the moment we got
to find a way of making it sound very
21st century we have to particularly add
direct our attention towards young
people you know one of the things I've
been doing in Europe is it going around
talking to high school students and I
know it sounds weird being a university
but I find it very interesting talking
to 17 18 year-olds before they go to
university because at that point is
still idealistic this they kind of feel
that they can make things happen they
haven't been sort of did having me kind
of ran down by the university ethos that
they're going to go into and if you can
somehow capture their imagination
inspire them by indicating there's a
different way of looking at the world
then you can at least build up a larger
cohort of more freedom loving more
freedom interested individuals and
there's always kids like that you know
who are you have a lot of energy within
them and they are looking to be inspired
and very often when they go to
university they will tell you that
they're being validated and and
everybody flatters them and everybody
tells them how wonderful they are but
it's very rare when they get really
stretched and they really feel that
something positive has occurred so that
I think all those things are really
important but I think above all I think
what we need to do is to challenge the
child-rearing socializing culture in a
more systematic way I think at the
moment people are very very very very
scared to actually make the point that
children you know are quite capable of
the agency the Kwakiutl is standing on
their feet we can we can treat them as
potential adults already at a very early
age and there's no reason why the
capacity for independence you should not
be cultivated not when they are 45 but
when they are six what we will leave it
there we have been talking with Frank
Ferretti he's a sociologist at the
University of Kent and he's the author
most recently of what's happened to the
university a sociological exploration of
its infantilization Frank thanks for
talking to us for reason I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]